What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And today we are back at the streets of Helsinki
This time we have 5 items
And we will play 1 match with each.
If our challengers manage to beat us
They will get 10 euros.
The weather isn't that great
But let's hope that people are up for the
challenge!
Alright, today we have 5 items.
This is the first match.
You get to choose which item I will play with!
The lamp!
The lamp?
Yep.
Who do you think will win this match?
I will!
You will?
It's good to be confident!
Let's start!
0-0!
So lucky for me.
Sorry!
0-3
1-5
Nice shot!
No chance
9-3
I had to try!
Thank you!
The lamp was pretty good!
I'll choose the scissors!
Alright!
That was somewhat expected
Let's go with these scissors!
That's a good handicap
1-0
Not a good start for me
I have the wind on my side
True
My first point!
5-4
It's a tight match!
6-6
It's getting a bit critical now
9-7
10-7
You have 3 match points
Good match!
You played well with the scissors!
Here is the prize
Keep the 10 euros
This was a fun afternoon exercise!
Are you sure?
Yeah, it's fine!
Alright, thanks!
Was fun to play!
Wow, what a guy!
Such a nice guy!
It was so challenging to play with the scissors.
It was the service
I couldn't somehow hit it
The wind was coming towards me
So it was very difficult to hit the ball...
Don't try to blame it on the wind!
You were just not very good.
Okay...
Maybe!
Okay
Which item shall I play with?
Pick the most difficult one!
Alright, let's go with the candle?
Yeah
Ok, let's see how it goes.
0-0
1-3
Nice!
4-3
This is fun!
Thank you!
Great!
You played well!
We have 2 items left
Which item do you want me to play with?
I'll choose this one
The iron
Great choice!
4-3
7-4
The wind made it short
Good try!
That was close!
Match point!
That was it
Thank you!
Nicely played
You were not far from winning!
Nope, didn't work
I had to try it
Miikka: Don't break my toaster!
Are you still using it?
I made my breakfast with it!
Nice shot!
I almost dropped the toaster!
I should probably hold on the cable
Yeah that was a good bluff
Let's take a new point
It's fine!
4-7
8-5.
My serve
Close!
10-6
The toaster seems to be good for this!
Alright, that was it!
Thank you!
It
was nice to play!
You were starting to get a good feeling for
the playing!
Alright, that's a wrap then for today
We had 5 items with us
We won 4 matches, lost 1
The only one that was causing some problems
Was the scissors
But, it's still pretty good
Hope you enjoyed this episode
If you have ideas what items we should use
next time
Comment below
Until next time!